un peu mieux,
les beatles font à nouveau l'actualité avec
le film
sur john lennon appelé imagine et un
livre
d'albert goldman qui est très
controversé
tu es célèbre d'une certaine manière parce que tu as été
le premier
batteur des beatles et ensuite tu as été
limogé et remplacé par  ringo starr
tu sais que tu as raté l'une des aventures les plus
marquantes du siècle
alors tu vas nous raconter ton histoire comment
tu as rencontré les beatles
j'ai rencontré les beatles en 1958 jerry ils ont
ouvert le club de ma mère le casper
quelle était ta relation avec eux
c'est  je veux dire ton
qui dans le groupe était ton meilleur
ami était-ce john ou paul ou
ou george non je pense qu'à cette époque c'était
john je
veux dire john et moi avons passé beaucoup de temps
ensemble à hambourg ouais
et quand nous sommes rentrés à la maison  à Liverpool,
sa maison était ma maison qui était dans sa
maison
et après avoir joué dans des concerts à
Liverpool et dans les environs, c'était toujours de retour chez
moi et nous jouions des disques et buvions de la
bière et nous saoulions ouais donc tu t'amuses beaucoup
tu racontes  tu es dans ton livre que john
lennon faisait pipi
pendant la nuit depuis un balcon quand tu étais
à hambourg
est-ce vrai c'est vrai ouais je veux dire ce que
tu dois retenir c'est quand nous étions
à hambourg nous ferions n'importe quoi pour rire
d'accord et cheong  était ce genre de gars qui
sauriez-vous si vous me mettiez au défi de le faire et
ce matin particulier
les nonnes étaient sur le chemin de l'église et
nous l'avons défié d'
être au-dessus des nonnes c'est vrai qu'il a
eu euh il a sorti son pantalon
euh et il ne porte que des slips et euh il a
mis son il a mis son cul juste sur
les visages des gens dans le club ouais on a
fait ça au kaiser keller on s'est
saoulé un soir
ouais et encore on a tous décidé qu'on
allait continuer  mettre en scène
et agir la chèvre euh georgie a continué avec
le siège des toilettes sur la tête
j'étais habillé avec des vêtements drôles mais
john a continué en maillot de bain
ouais et à mi-chemin du numéro ouais
tu viens de laisser tomber le maillot de bain
d'accord tournez ce dos vers le  public
et nous sommes à peu près aussi proches que ce que nous sommes
les uns des autres maintenant,
donc les gens dansaient avec les fesses de John
devant vous comme ça
est-il vrai aussi qu'il
s'est fait passer pour adolf hitler et
il a dit zigal zigel quand il était
dans les rues ou ouais ouais c'était euh
c'était une façon de relâcher la tension ouais
plus le fait que les allemands à cette
époque
s'attendaient à ce que nous fassions
des choses scandaleuses ouais d'accord et john était l'un de
ces gars d'accord
voir kyle avec hitler et réalisé  ce que
hitler était ici pendant la guerre
il pensait que c'était drôle tu sais et les
allemands pensaient que c'était drôle aussi
tu as rencontré albert goldman quand il
préparait son livre
non je n'ai jamais vendu la culture de ma
vie oui
il dit dans son  livre que john lennon
quand vous portez à hambourg ensemble
il dit que john lennon a tué le
marin est-ce vrai
non n'a pas tué de marin c'est dans ma
botte
mais ce que nous avons fait nous avons montré l'argent que
nous avions dépensé tout notre argent pour boire
les femmes et tout le reste
et le marin était là et il
nous avait acheté des boissons et vous savez qu'il nous a
emmenés pour un repas
et John et moi avons décidé que nous allions
rouler ouais vous savez pincez son portefeuille et
faites une course ici
mais  ce n'était pas un moyen de l'assassiner
albert goldman dit aussi dans son livre que
john lennon avait un amour pour elle avec brian
epstein
que john était homosexuel et avait une
histoire d'amour avec
brian epstein est-ce vrai je ne saurais pas que
je serai  tout à fait honnête à propos de cela,
c'est peut-être quelque chose qui
s'est passé après que j'étais avec le groupe, beaucoup
de gens se sont retournés et ont dit que c'était
arrivé, beaucoup de gens se sont allumés et ont
dit que cela ne s'était pas produit,
je ne sais pas vraiment comment c'était  vous vous battez
du groupe
comment vous ont-ils remplacé par richard
starkey alias
ringo starr qui jouait dans un autre
groupe appelé
rory storm and the hurricanes comment avez-
vous été viré j'ai été appelé dans le
bureau de brian epstein nous avons joué à la cabine
la veille ouais
et  j'ai été appelé au bureau pour le
suivre et ce n'était pas un
gros problème parce que j'ai déjà été appelé
au bureau parce qu'avant que
Brian ne soit le directeur, j'étais le
directeur
et c'était juste une question de discuter
des prix pour la banque  Je pensais que ça
allait juste être une autre réunion d'affaires
ouais
et quand je suis arrivé, je pouvais dire que
Brian était un peu inquiet, il
était nerveux,
puis après avoir parlé du
sujet pendant environ cinq ou dix minutes,
il s'est juste retourné, a-t-il dit  petey a dit que j'ai de
mauvaises nouvelles pour vous
les garçons veulent que vous sortiez et ils veulent
ringo ouais
et c'était coupé et séché la sonnerie allait
devenir abandonnée
la raison pour laquelle il l'a donnée cette théorie du temps
était que ce n'était pas un bon  assez de batteur
et ça et il pensait que ringo starr
était un bon batteur
qu'ils avaient peut-être je n'ai pas euh et il y a
beaucoup d'autres personnes qui pensent qu'il
n'est pas
ouais mais ce qui s'est passé, c'est que nous avons découvert
par la suite
que la vraie vérité derrière  c'était qu'ils
étaient jaloux ouais
simplement à cause de tes yeux tu avais plus de
succès avec les filles
eh bien oui je l'ai fait euh c'est une de ces
choses il y a toujours quelqu'un dans le
groupe qui aura
eu un peu plus de chance que les
autres et c'est juste  il s'est passé que
j'ai eu plus que ce qu'ils ont fait ouais alors
mais tu as rencontré les beatles après ou tu leur as
parlé je les ai rencontrés à trois
reprises
j'ai joué deux fois sur le même projet de loi qu'eux
et une fois quand ils
enregistraient pour la bbc au  Cabine,
le plus drôle, c'est que nous n'avons pas parlé, nous sommes
passés comme des navires dans la nuit
et de ce jour à ce jour, euh, ils ont
suivi leur chemin et j'ai suivi le mien,
quelle a été votre réaction pendant Mitel
Mania,
c'était génial de réaliser que  la vérité
que nous nous sentions bien parce que même quand j'étais
avec le groupe, nous avons réalisé que nous
allions aller ailleurs
ouais et même si je n'en faisais pas partie,
c'était agréable
de voir que d'accord, la réalisation est que
oui et si les gens  pouvait se voir
que oui, ils étaient quelque chose de différent
ouais
te laisser porter des chinos que tu portes triste
triste ouais parce que j'étais sur le point d'
en faire partie
mais euh c'était un cas de recul correct
les voir les apprécier et leur souhaiter
le meilleur
mais toi  t'as essayé tu n'as pas essayé de
devenir une rock star par toi-
même après oh ouais ouais
je veux dire j'ai rejoint un autre groupe appelé
leakers for the oil starts
puis j'ai formé mon propre groupe le pink
s4 qui est devenu plus tard le combo pré-presse
et nous  Je suis allé en Amérique
et j'ai fait le tour du monde, mais euh,
ce n'était pas vraiment censé être ouais, nous n'avons tout simplement
pas eu les bons freins,
c'est vrai que vous avez essayé de vous
suicider, ouais,
c'était marron vers 1964.
Ouais et c'était dans le noir.  de la nuit
et c'était une de ces choses qui était
déprimée
ouais le groupe n'avançait pas aussi vite qu'il
aurait dû l'être et je n'ai pas fait de
notes de suicide ou quoi que ce soit du tout comme
ça c'est juste une sorte de fraction de seconde
décision ouais
et heureusement mon frère m'a sauvé
et j'ai fait un vœu à partir de ce jour-là
cette chose ne se reproduira plus jamais ouais
quelle a été ta réaction quand tu
écoutes le chemin de la radio et quand tu
apprends
le tournage de john lennon ça m'a bouleversé
euh
beaucoup de gens se sont retournés et ont
dit quelle différence cela ferait-il,
c'était le gars qui faisait partie d'un groupe
qui a viré il y a 20 ans,
mais ce que les gens n'ont pas réalisé
ici, c'est que j'étais proche de John,
je connaissais le  mec pendant quatre ans personnellement
avant la séparation
et j'ai des numéros très très amusants tu
écoutes des
disques amers oh ouais tu dois t'avoir je
les ai vraiment entendus sur le
disque tu sais la radio
ils sont à la télévision je veux dire non
peu importe où vous allez dans le monde, vous
avez toujours des disques de coléoptères super
vous pensez que vous avez raté votre vie non
c'est agréable d'être regardé en arrière et de dire
comment dire ouais j'en faisais partie
ouais et c'est quelque chose qu'ils ne pourront
jamais enlever et si nous  si c'était à
refaire,
est-ce que tu te battrais beaucoup plus pour rester dans la
pièce
oh oui ouais je pense euh je n'avais pas mon mot à dire sur
la
façon dont ça a été fait en 1962 mais si je
savais que ça allait se reproduire
alors je '  d assurez-vous que je ne peux pas opposer
une résistance plus forte pensez-vous que
vous êtes
un meilleur batteur que ringo starr
court et doux oui
vous